(cris des manifestants)
(buhuhaha)
- Au Sri Lanka, les jeunes
le gouvernement en juillet
étaient encore dans les eses
de la capitale aujourd'hui.
Ils dénoncent depuis cinq mois
contre une inflationalalopante,
qui a atteint 70 %
en septembre. Les tablettesinin;
le pays est en faillite.
L'Indonésie est aussi paralysée.
Depuis le début de l'année, il y
contre la flambée des prix de
l'essence et des aliments.
(cris des manifestants)
À Cuba, des citoyens ont
protesté vendredi soir
contre les coupures de courant
du réseau électrique du pays est
utilisé, faute de pétrole et de
pièces pour réparer les pannes.
d'espèces.
"Tout est très dispendieux,
dit cette Cubaine,
(détonation)
En É
pays, les manifestations contre
la vie cèère ont été violemment
réprimées.
"Nous marchions de façon
pacifique, dit cet étudiant,
jusqu'à ce que la policettttttt"
Selon une compilation de la BBC,
depuis le début de l'année, 92
contre la hausse du coût de
la vie. La répression de ces
mouvements aurait fait au moins
de pays.
C'est la Sierra Leone qui
enregist
27 citoyens et six policiers ont
pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest, le
prix du panier d'épicerie a plus
que doublé en moin
JEAN-THOMAS BERNARD, professeur
d'économ, , Université d'Ottawa
- C'est vraiment une situation
très diff
Ces gouvernements-là sont
souvent démus s et ils ont pas
la possibilité d'avoir des
programmes d
convenables pour cette situation
dramatique.
- Pour ce spécialisteététététét,
les gouvernements ont peu
de moyens pour contrer le prix
élevé du pétrole. Geler oux x xe
n'aident pas les plus démunis.
- Si nous, les paysinininininint
des prix artificiellement ba
la quantité qui est disponible
viendra plus vers les paysduduÉ,
ça rend encore la situation
davantage précaire pour les pays
pauvres.
- Selon l'économiste,
la seule chose utile que
nos gouvernements peuvent faire,
aux citoyens qui ont un revenu
momodeste. Les employeurs aussi
peuvent aider.
l'Espagne, l'Allemagne
et'A'Angleterre subissent
la pression de la rue.
LORENZO
syndicats chrétiens, Belgique
- La vie est devenue invivable.
Les gens ne s'en sortent plus.
À un moment donné, on veut quets
forts, il faut des augmentations
salariales.
- En E
les syndicats qui organisent
les manifeatations.
La Commission européenne a réagi
aujourd'hu
les pays membres vont discuter
jeudi d'une série de mesures,dux
à la pompe.
Ici Sophie Langlois,
Radio-Canada, Montréa